hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well near the end of
chapter two of on Liberty John Stuart
Mill is going to consider the
application of his general principles in
particular the harm principle not just
to whether you know freedom or Liberty
of expression ought to be allowed and
and why it ought to be allowed but also
the manner in which people are
expressing things to each other so he's
moving from the that to the how and he
says that it's fit to take some notice
of those who say that the free
expression of all opinions should be
permitted so that's going along with his
main idea on condition that the manner
be temperate and do not pass the bounds
of fair discussion so we have some
old-timey language there that requires a
little bit of unpacking they're saying
that free expression so that would
include you know talking posting things
today on internet forums publishing
things shooting videos any of that
service a free expression should be
allowed so long as it meets two
different conditions and it could fail
either one of those conditions one is
that its temperate we don't use
that term all that often and if you're
thinking in terms of virtue ethics Mill
doesn't mean temper it in the same way
that we talk about temper rents except
in a rather convoluted manner so we'll
come back to that in a moment but this
other one does not pass the bounds of
fair discussion I think that's a little
bit easier for us to grasp we often say
that somebody is transgressing a limit
or they're going too far with something
and we have you know sense of what
constitutes fair discussion so you know
for example using ad hominem attacks
most people do view that as going you
know beyond the pale and if you've got
to make ad hominem attacks you're kind
of disqualifying yourself but there's
plenty of people out there who don't
actually realize that and we'll come to
that in a moment but be that as it may
we can say look there there's some some
basic unwritten rules about what
constitutes fair discussion can't we or
at least within certain circumstances
certain formats we can say well this is
the way that you should behave so coming
back to the temper thing what is it to
be temperate it means that you're
essentially being civil with the other
person you're not allowing yourself to
get too worked up you're not saying
things in us you know strain of
invective or to use another word that
he's going to use a little bit later by
toupper a ssin all right
which means saying that somebody else is
vicious so free expression should be
allowed so long as it meets those those
requirements if it doesn't meet those
requirements then shut it down you know
condemn it with the force of public
opinion if it's on some sort of you know
media platform get rid of it maybe the
state can step in and regulate it people
can be hired and fired on these basis
all these sorts of things right that
that would be what he's talking about
here so mill points out some problems
with this and these are not absolutely
insurmountable but there's certainly
things that one would have to
take account of if there's going to be
some sort of control on this first he
says there's a difficulty in saying
where these actual limits are brought up
the idea of unwritten rules unwritten
rules are always difficult even written
rules are subject to all sorts of
reinterpretation if you've ever had an
argument with somebody over a board game
about how exactly a rule is to be
interpreted what it applies to
you have a good sense of just imagine
there weren't any written rules and
everyone just kind of you know sensed
what they are now you'd have an even
tougher time wouldn't you now in this
case Mill talks about making the test
being offense to those whose opinion is
attacked and he says this is not a good
idea why not
he says experience tells us that this
offense is given whenever certain things
happen whenever the attack is telling
and powerful so you you actually you
know drive it home quite well whenever
there is an opponent who pushes them
hard and who they find it difficult to
answer this appears to that person if he
shows any strong feeling on the subject
and in temperate opponent an opponent
who's not fair an opponent who is not
playing by the rules right who's being
mean to them who's you know saying the
wrong thing going where they shouldn't
go however we want to frame it if we
make whether somebody else takes offense
to it the main criterion then we're
gonna have to rule out an awful lot of
language right and you know we can also
consider the fact that over time some
things that weren't considered to be
offensive or at least weren't marked as
being offensive by people then become
offensive later on there's changes in
vocabulary that you can use there's
changes in the ways that you can talk to
people so Mill says this is really not
going to work very well and he says
there's a bigger problem though as
Wow he says here we go the principal
offenses of the kind are such as it is
mostly impossible unless by accidental
self-betrayal to bring home to
conviction the gravest of them is to
argue sophistical II when we call
somebody a sophist those echoes back to
ancient Greece where there are these
people who called themselves sometimes
Sophists sometimes there's teachers of
rhetoric and went around teaching people
how to make strong arguments
particularly in legal settings but you
know we can also talk about the court of
public opinion here as well and arguing
sophistical ii means to argue in ways
that strictly speaking aren't fair so
Mill gives you some examples suppressing
facts or arguments you know ignoring the
good arguments that your opponents have
suppressing facts ignoring them saying
that they're not true saying we won't
talk about that sort of thing that's
very common in in arguments about
controversial topics he gives them some
other examples of sophistical things to
miss state the elements of the case
isn't that a great 1 or 2 miss represent
the opposite opinion what we often call
straw Manning right even steel Manning
can turn into straw man steel Manning is
when you you know are supposed to make
your opponent's case stronger but
there's ways of doing that which turn
out to actually be straw Manning as well
when you misrepresent the person's
argument what it is that they're they're
actually claiming we could go into that
as a separate topic some other time
there's interesting strategies at work
here we can also talk about people who
use true premises and generate a false
inference from that you know a false
narrative where parts of it are true but
it's the way that they're arranged that
gives a false conclusion to it so that's
all sophistical right and Mill points
out that many people who do in fact make
false claims or false arguments and
we're
argue unfairly are doing so in good
faith they are not realizing that they
are doing that and he says all of this
even to the most aggravated agree is so
continually done in perfect good-faith
by persons who are not considered and in
many other respects may not deserve to
be considered ignorant or incompetent
that's rarely possible to stamp the
misrepresentation as morally culpable
and still less could law presume to
interfere with this kind of
controversial misconduct so calls for
the law stepping in and keeping people
from saying things that aren't true
except you know within certain
circumstances like not perjuring
themselves in a court of law or you're
not committing fraud those sorts of
things
Mill sees that is essentially a
non-starter it's not going to work he
also considers another thing that's
really quite important he asks ok
let's go into a little bit more detail
about what is intemperate discussion
who says invective sarcasm personality
that means attacks on persons I believe
and the like a little bit later on he
talks about polemic and stigmatizing
those who hold the contrary opinion is
bad and immoral people calumny vie to
parade right so these are all ways of
talking about saying saying bad things
about people talking trash about people
right that person is only taking that
stand because they're a dirty communist
or they're a dirty capitalist or there
are this and that right whatever it's
going to be he says that denunciation of
these weapons would deserve more
sympathy meaning we'd consider this more
more fair if it were ever proposed to
introductive
to both sides now that's an interesting
proposal right he's saying most people
who want to say that somebody else is
being uncivil intemperate in these terms
is accusing the other side of doing it
but very
rarely extending that same criterion
consistently to their own side as we
sometimes say today policing their own
right so if you're a Republican and
you're attacking the Democrats for all
the mean things that they're saying
about your candidates or your president
well then you better be looking at the
mean things you're saying and your
fellow Republicans are saying about
Democratic candidates as well or else
you're kind of full of it you're really
just picking sides and you're not all
right you're not criticizing in good
faith so he says that it's only desire
to restrain the employment to them
against the prevailing opinion against
the unproven they may not only be used
without general disapproval but will be
likely to obtain for him who uses the
praise of Ana's zeal and righteous
indignation and so you know Mill is not
framing it in terms of political parties
here he's framing it in terms of what
the prevailing opinion is the you know
current social assumptions mores and
anything opposed to it so you know if we
take something that's that's quite
controversial now and I imagine will
remain controversial into the future you
know something like say polygamy if we
say you know polygamy is simply wrong
and exploitative and it's bad for you
know women and all of that those are
claims that we could make if we call
people who are advocating for it a bunch
of dirty wife swappers or something like
that that might be allowed to pass
because it's in favor of the prevailing
opinion right and what the prevailing
opinion is going to vary from place to
place to place so you know in Mills time
traditional religious belief was the
prevailing opinion and disbelief or you
know being a critic of religion was
being an orthodox in today's for you
know framework in many places being a
traditional religious believer might
actually place you in the
already over here and other people will
you know engage in invective against
your religion or its representatives or
its tax or its actions or its putative
history or anything like that and so
Mill points out that this is a very
common dynamic people are not consistent
in their application of this and he says
whatever mischief arises from the use of
this this harsh language its greatest
when it's employed against the
comparatively defenseless so you know
the people you know we talk in comedy
about punching down for example as
opposed to punching up why is it okay to
punch up but not to punch down at least
this you know that's the prevailing
opinion now I don't think it was fifty
years ago because there's a sense in
which you know somebody being satirized
for various traits if they're an elected
public official they actually have quite
a lot of power if they're a rich person
they've got plenty of money if they're a
celebrity they've got plenty of fame but
some you know Joe Schmo down here is
much more vulnerable and could be in
many respects hurt quite a bit more by
them so Mill thinks that that we
shouldn't be engaging in this but we
should realize that if we try to
restrict it we really need to do it to
protect a vulnerable rather than those
who have power prestige money whatever
other advantages now Mill himself is
actually pretty hands-off when it comes
to this he has some some suggestions he
thinks that the law itself should not
restrain vituperative language except
you know things that we can already
identify as problems libel slander those
those sorts of things you know in order
to show that something is libel you've
got to show that it's false and
generally you have to show some damages
accruing from it I know there's
different ways of construing this in
different parts of the world so we don't
need to get bogged down and those things
but Mill thinks that the law itself is
he says law and authority have no
business interest reigning either
attacks on infidelity or religion right
and then he says what we should do
instead is that opinion and by this he
means public opinion he means the
sanction of publicity opinion ought to
judge cases individually if we think
that somebody is being intemperate we
ought to call them out on that on that
particular case he also says that we
should not infer vices from the side a
person takes though it be the contrary
side of the question to our own and so
what we ought to do that is we ought to
be looking at what people say and not
worrying so much about as we say
nowadays tone policing or ruling people
out or canceling people because they
said things in ways we don't like we can
certainly criticize them for that we can
say I think you're being we won't say I
don't think you're being intemperate
we'll say I think you're being uncivil
or I think you're being kind of a jerk
in the way that you're expressing things
I think you're being tendentious that's
that's a good one what is somebody being
tendentious somebody who's just arguing
a bad case to argue it because they're
invested in it it's perfectly fine to
point that out but saying that we ought
to restrain them by law from doing that
sort of thing mill does not want that to
be to be done so he wants them quite a
lot of scope for the tone the manner the
language choice that people use in
making their cases and expressing their
opinions
you